adopté en 1949 à l'âge de 4 mois
diane poitras a toujours voulu savoir
d'où elle vient reste à savoir qui chie
louvier depuis le 13 juin dernier les
enfants adoptés au québec peuvent
obtenir l'identité de leurs parents
biologiques
s'ils sont décédés diane poitras qui a
longtemps milité pour le droit des
enfants adoptés a été parmi les
premières à envoyer sa demande mais
l'attenté a été longue à se plaisent la
goutte d'eau le 18 octobre
elle a reçu le coup de téléphone tant
attendue et elle a appris l'identité de
sa mère
il s'agit de yanina une immigrante
d'origine polonaise qui a survécu aux
camps de concentration
lorsque j'aurai nombre ma main je leur
serai sûrement car diane poitras a
continué ses recherches pour en
apprendre plus sur l'histoire de yanina
elle a appris que sa mère est arrivée il
ya exactement soixante dix ans sur un
bateau qui a accosté à halifax durant le
temps des fêtes
avant de se rendre à montréal madame
poitras a contacté les soeurs du bon
conseil à montréal qui accueillait les
immigrants 1948
j'ai raconté mon histoire sur martienne
puis elle m'a dit la dette
les dates d'arrivée une ma mère au
canada qui le 23 24 décembre les
désignant diane poitras aurait un
deuxième frère et à la sptr contacté sa
famille biologique prochainement
exactement soixante dix ans après
l'arrivée de sa mère au pays
madame poitras commence à avoir les
réponses aux questions qu'ils ont habité
depuis si longtemps
le plus beau des cadeaux pour noël ici
nayla bendali radio canada lévy